alors on commence ce soir Véronique par
un marché géant sur l'art à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye exactement l'art
contemporain c'est sur la place du
marché place du Marché Neuf à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye salle lieu samedi
17 juin de 10h à 19h il y a plus d'une
centaine de d'artistes qui exposent
différentes œuvres évidemment ils ont un
stand chacun c'est un événement qui
existe depuis 2007 donc là on est sur la
15e édition au départ ça groupe d'amis
qu'on voulait
exprimer leur intérêt pour l'art
contemporain qu'on crée cet événement et
puis après ça a été repris par Cécile
coutant directrice de l'Atelier pièces
unique à Saint-Germain-en-Laye et ben
voilà donc ça ça marche très bien vous
avez des pins des sculpteurs des
aquarellistes des photographes des
graveurs etc et surtout il y a une
sélection sur le dossier ils sont des
professionnels donc il y a une garantie
de qualité et donc vous c'est génial de
voir autant d'arts de peintres et de
d'artistes contemporains en même temps
sur le même lieu et moi je fais un petit
coucou un petit coup de coeur au peintre
Serda qui sera au stand 12 qui des
toiles magnifiques très colorées et qui
m'a donné cette information donc elle
mérite bien coucou Sarda on poursuit vos
insolites Véronique avec du rugby oui
parce qu'il y a pas que l'art dans la
vidéo c'est le sport ma petite dame
alors c'est un tournoi qu'on connaît
parce qu'il existe même depuis c'est la
10e édition c'est le tournoi caritatif
de rugby à 7 ça s'appelle set de coeur
c'est une association au départ c'est de
Benoît Benoît Moreau deux amis enfin ça
y est qui avait dans la famille des
enfants malades d'une maladie génétique
donc était particulièrement touchée par
ce problème et sensible et qui était des
rues humaines professionnelles et qui
ont qui ont utilisé lors les cachets
qu'il gagnait en faisant des tournois
pour donc aider les associations et
après ils ont eu l'idée de se regrouper
enfin d'être plusieurs ils sont ils sont
une base de 10 bénévoles et puis 80 pour
les événements bien sûr et pas mal de
Versailles et ça a lieu donc sur le
stade porschefontaine de Porchefontaine
à Versailles RER C c'est sur deux jours
17 18 juin toute la journée vous avez
donc des
pardon donc le but c'était de d'aider
les de ramasser de lever des fonds pour
aider des associations en rapport avec
les enfants malades voilà vous avez donc
plein d'animations vous avez surtout des
tournois justement du rugby à 7 alors
pour être rugby à 7 ça vous savez
Mathilde
cette année mais sinon on peut faire du
rugby à 5 on peut faire du du bodge
attendez au secours Dodgeball vous savez
ce que c'est non c'est la balle au
prisonnier de du 19e siècle de mon
époque d'accord
vous allez pouvoir y rejouer il y a des
structures gonflables pour les enfants
plein d'animations il y a de quoi se
restaurer c'est très éco-responsable ils
ont une machine qui va composter des
déchets réduire en poudre sur place et
surtout il y a une vente aux enchères
sur qui est en ligne déjà de t-shirts de
grands champions si vous voulez vous
offrir un t-shirt de champion de rugby
il y a deux stars du rugby qui vont les
parents qui sont présents en riches
avancy imaginez-vous et Isabelle
Ithurburu qui est la présentatrice sur
Canal+ de de munition de rugby voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre c'est une
information pour notre journaliste
Nicolas dré mais voilà il faut qu'il les
invite Nicolas ou qu'il y a et gnagnagna
voilà donc c'est des équipes de haut
niveau puisqu'ils sont licenciés après
il y a deux il y a 22 équipes féminines
24 masculines des équipes de rugby à 5
et il faut absolument y aller c'est
toute la journée sur deux jours voilà
alors on continue vos informations
insolites Véronique
maintenant
ça vous fait rêver ça m'intéresse en
tout cas ça s'appelle l'escrime
artistique en fait c'est une association
qui s'appelle la garde des clés qui a
été montée par Eric bounique qui existe
depuis un certain temps notamment au
Clayes-sous-Bois et qui propose un
spectacle vendredi 16 juin alors pour
arriver à 19h30 ça démarre à 20h c'est à
l'espace Philippe Noiret donc aux
Clayes-sous-Bois c'est une comédie de
cap et d'épée qui sont très sur scène
c'est pour tous les âges c'est assez
burlesque rigolo à un moment il y a un
ours alors je vous le dis les faux comme
ça on prend pas peur mais bon voilà et
c'est eux qui font les costumes les
décors etc parce que les artistique la
différence avec les screen normal c'est
que au lieu de vouloir se toucher comme
normal on ne se touche pas puisqu'on a
pas de protection donc c'est un petit
peu dangereux donc voilà après ce sont
des combats qui sont chorégraphiés très
très mesuré millimétré parce que
justement toujours par sécurité la
question de se mettre à ce moment là et
du coup c'est très très organisé c'est
un peu comme une chorégraphie d'ailleurs
chez Louis XIV souvenez-vous la danse
l'escrime c'est souvent les mêmes
personnes les danseurs et les breiteurs
car on dit breetter car on Brette et
aussi une dernière petite info que m'a
donné Eric c'est que les les on dit
bastonner bât parce que les pauvres
n'avaient pas de
d'épée vous avez des bateaux donc
bâtonnets bastonné et les riches avaient
des ça y est je me suis un peu du nom
hier au secours faut pas m'aider rapière
rapière voilà j'aurais pas pu vous aider
donc là il y a ce spectacle qui va être
enregistré parce que ça va être un test
ils espèrent être au moins Muller
l'année prochaine et donc il propose des
cours des stream artistiques aux
Clayes-sous-Bois il faut aller au forum
des associations Coralie en septembre
par exemple vous tapez l'association je
vous ai dit c'est la garde des clés et
on apprend l'escrime artistique mais on
apprend aussi enfin c'est un ensemble en
fait vous faites des vous concevez le
spectacle bien merci Véronique et
Turbide on passe rapidement à votre
dernière information vous vouliez
terminé par votre dernier VIP vérifie à
la ferme de Richard aquaponi voilà on
aquaponie c'est du système de des
poissons système vertueux les poissons
l'eau des poissons nourrit les plantes
machin et il fait une journée portes
ouvertes samedi 17 charger votre samedi
matin
ah c'est un nom là
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
et bien merci beaucoup Véronique encore
une fois